for the first five days we don't know
where she was so the family members
another day they're running like crazy
in the style it was nowhere to be found
we thought that she was been killed
because she was not arrested by the
police force she was arrested by the
soldiers in the Marines nope we most
arbitrary owes Tommy justly hey she's
been working on when the indigenous
communities since 2004 she traveled to
Mexico like three four times are you so
she can bring some claws you know in
donations to the burpee I since two
thousand gold she has been involved when
the community police forces
she was arrested because that in 2013 I
was twenty first and since then she's
been a maximum security prison the local
judges and stare arrow and the
politicians they want to see the story
in prison they are refusing to let ago
when you know the UN naka mean any type
of crime and the next day you family
member it's not it's not an alibi jail
she's in a maxima and a maximum security
prison a thousand miles away he's
brutally difficult solos amigos podemos
hacer algo podemos hacer que esta esta
en constancy an awesome bono right he
and I I have few copies you know
different letters you know they have
been sent to john kerry you know what I
feel is a the city permit has done
nothing to help us to release my way
they had a power
I'm gonna meet when Aaron Smith and we
only keep knocking doors and maybe
somebody else can listen to us she's a
solitary confinement the federal judge
to order for her to be released as much
Tori Telfer chillin spent almost seven
eight months already some local judges
and local politicians there is to try to
keep her you know but love is possible
you will definitely stay in touch we
will talk to you in the State Department
and see what we can do there to prod
them to be more helpful to put more
pressure and it's at this point it's all
about the governor one two three
I get nervous but you know I try to
focus you know mind remembers you know
in my wife you know to tina whore you
know i am not used to be in front of
microphones and i am I used to being
implanted cameras and but you know for
my why you know I do anything I don't
care you know hot on the taste but i
wanna keep doing it it's my why what is
in prison I'm innocent person